somebody's trying to get in superhero
shapes it is I see you
there is an important conversation that
doesn't happen without you I love it
listen I was just talking to Rita Moreno
and her grandson Justin
and we were talking about how this role
for her came about okay I will be honest
it was my idea to get her in Fast and
Furious time well we were at the opening
of West Side Story the new one and Vin
Diesel was there and we caught up and
grabbed drinks after the event and he's
so fun to my grandma and I told him you
should work with her you should ever be
your grandma have her slap you upside
the head have her have a little tone
because you know her it's all tone I
should I should give him a uh does he
get a cut an agent yeah why not okay why
was it number one a big yes for you yes
and why was it so important to have her
great question
um
so much of the Saga has
kind of
been about fatherhood yeah
the first film
that quintessential moment in the first
film Dom is talking about his father
and
at some point
uh I felt like the audience would need
to see some of the
incredible
females
that have led to this film that have
been responsible for this
for Dom and this family that uh kind of
gravitates around this character where
some of these ideals come from and in
nine we play with the with Dom's Father
which is Jack you're introduced to Jack
and so it was a natural kind of thing to
say here's the abuela
um and when we think of someone like
Rita Moreno she my hero has always been
Sidney Poitier so my whole life I had
been on like Sidney Poitier was the guy
that opened the doors for my father and
everybody in the world
but five years earlier
Rita Moreno won an Oscar and nobody
really really thinks about that and kind
of
it realizes how much of a Pioneer she
was and so the Latin Community has
always embraced this family so deeply
and and we've always responded by the
incredible cast that we've included like
Don Omar and Tego Calderon and there was
something special about saying this
iconic character
this Regal and incredible talent in Rita
Moreno is responsible for the DNA of the
Toronto I love that you're not
naughty Larson into this and then you've
got Jason Momoa as well playing the
villain you've had you've come up
against some villains so how
what kind the thing the thing about
Jesus so I've
been wanting to find something to do or
bring Jason in for 10 years I think when
I did
um Riddick about 10 years ago I was
already looking at this guy saying let's
get him in
um what I liked about
Jason Momo's approach to this character
was he was trying to do something that
was unique to The Fast and Furious and
that excites me and that excites
everybody he was coming in with a really
fresh and you'll see when you see the
movie he comes in with such a fresh and
unique
approach a take on playing the classic
villain in our franchise and I think
that's one of the things that allows you
to keep going
um which is constantly trying to defy
expectations I know you always honoring
Paul I see it by your shirt today I know
you guys are going to honor him in these
films too you know the fan theory is
that Brie Larson could be his sister
I love a good fan Theory I love a good
fan Theory
[Music]